[Music]
good evening my name is Alexander rose
I'm the executive director at long now
and just wanted to note a couple things
coming up as many of you know we also
run a smaller lecture series at the
interval and a lot of people always ask
how you get tickets because there's only
50 of them and they sell out very fast
those of you that are members know that
you get advance notice of those tickets
and that's pretty much fills the room
very quickly just with that notification
so with that the the next two talks that
we have coming up one is with the editor
at imbibe magazine who's gonna be
talking about the next 150 years of
cocktails be a great one to have at the
interval the the one after that is going
to be with Andy weir author of the
Martian talking about the science behind
the Martian that will sell out probably
really fast so hit the button quickly
and the other thing that we often do
with these talks is what's called a long
short short film that exemplifies long
term thinking and tonight's is one that
we've been actually looking at for quite
a long time that I think will set a
pretty contemplative tone for tonight's
talk sit back and enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
the history of civilization some people
say is the history of cities hi I'm
Stuart brand from the long now
foundation if you ask an architecture
what is infrastructure they'll typically
say well it's something gray behind a
chain-link fence and that means an
infrastructure usually is hidden maybe
for security reasons maybe for aesthetic
reasons civilization doesn't really want
you to know about it or think about it
or [ __ ] with it and except for bridges
it's basically hidden that's when infer
means infrared has more heat infrared
from the Sun than all of the light in
the visual part of the spectrum the
infra part we don't see so in a sense
infrastructure is the hidden history of
civilization
maybe it's the hidden future of
civilization talk about that please
welcome Jim fallows
[Applause]
thank you much so much Stuart thank you
all for coming out this evening it
really is a privilege to to be here I
had two thoughts on watching that
wonderful film one is for any of you who
have lived in China if we have is just
like watching TV in China so I felt
right right back at home in terms of the
the the quick stimulation the other is
it's why you're going to here for the
next few minutes I'm gonna be just
talking to you as opposed to having a
slide presentation because my snapshots
would be disappointing after after that
kind of film but I'm gonna try to
explain why I think infrastructure
actually is interesting let me give you
some some prelude for this first I do
have to say without taking too much time
what a honor and privilege it is for my
wife and Deb who's here in the front row
visiting our son Tom was also next to
her and to be here with so many of our
friends I can't actually see you through
the lights right now but beforehand I
saw many friends here and so we're we're
honored for your coming out we also it's
more than sort of just just a homecoming
more than a casual homecoming to to be
here in a sense this is our literal
former home back in 2000 and 2001 Deb
and I lived in the East Bay in Berkeley
when she was working at oxygen if you
remember them on South Market Street I
think or South Main Street I was
teaching at UC Berkeley with Katie
Hefner and working for the
industry-standard if you remember that
too and we've been back and forth but
this is still our spiritual home in a
lot of ways I will confess in this crowd
I actually was I grew up in Southern
California so I know that is one of the
great divides between north and south
but we've spent so much time here over
the years personally and
journalistically that I was really glad
to have a chance to sort of touch base
with all of you and for a way that
you've heard from a lot of other
reporters visiting from the east coast
but I wanted to explain in a little
little more more depth over the last now
thirty plus years 35 years like work for
the Atlantic at least every year so I've
come here for reporting trips and not
for what you would normally read from
your your your East Coast journalists
about oh gee whiz they are so hip and
Kelly
fornia they're not talking about the
sequester they're talking about the
future etc what I have found so
engrossing here in my home state of
California and my adopted home area of
the Bay Area is that everything that is
interesting in the world you can see on
display here yeah of course you can see
the tech changes in recent years you've
seen the manufacturing changes
educational innovation at the high end
and at other end you see here the
changes in governance that California
has gone through over the last last
decade I I've ended up feeling in more
than a cliched way or rediscovering it
after taking it for granted when growing
up here
the California really is the America of
America by which I mean not just the
fact the trends and fashions start here
but that everything that is challenging
in our national life and promising in
our national life in terms of
technological disruption ethnic change
and all the rest you can see here in a
way that is both more challenging and in
many ways more hopeful than in then in
other parts of the country so that's why
I've been glad to come here and now I'll
explain why the last couple of months of
correspondence between me and Stuart has
been different from most other
engagements of this sort that I've done
most people in this audience I bet have
four or five or six subjects on which
they can roll off a standard pitch and
if you wanted a speech right now on the
prospects for China or what's gonna
happen the presidential race or things
like that I could give you that standard
pitch but Stuart a number of months ago
he said that he would like me to think
about this subject of infrastructure as
it intersected with the long nails
perspective I'd been writing a series on
the California high-speed rail project
of which I was a proponent and am I know
that's not the universal view but I was
doing this series in the Atlantic and so
I said yes I'll try to think about this
and so what you're going to see is that
unusual thing from a journalist a guy
who's just gotten here from the East
Coast and agit hack and all that that is
the product my actually trying to think
about this and trying to say what do I
know that that is that that
I shed some light for it for all of you
at the Atlantic we have a particular
goal that's kept us going now for our
hundred and fifty eight years of
existence I know there are some people
from unicorn companies here in the room
the Atlantic is a kind of publishing
world unicorn that we still exist yeah
we are we've every day that's up for
renegotiation but we're profitable now
we've the thing we brag about among many
things is that we we made only one
presidential endorsement in our history
that was for Abraham Lincoln in 1860 and
so we decided we retire undefeated with
it with that and so but but what we try
to do in our articles since we have very
specialized circumstances in which we
write we have a very long lead time
we're usually thinking a year ahead of
time of what's going to be the subject
for an article trying to imagine what
will be prominent enough to be
interesting a year from now but the New
York Times won't have gotten to it and
then circumstances won't have changed
the entire premises the goal we've had
is to do arguments or analyses of
subjects that become obvious once
they're pointed out that is things that
once once the presentation is over
you've read the article you've heard the
page you think well of course but you
didn't think of course before you'd
heard this argument and I could give you
a long list of ways we've tried to try
to do that but my goal in these next few
minutes is to tell you something that I
hope will seem obvious once I explain it
about the role how to think about
infrastructure for people citizens of
the world citizens of the United States
citizens of California and members of
the tech industry who are abundantly
represented in this room so that is the
goal I believe in the school of oratory
in which you tell people were going to
tell them you tell them and you tell
them what you told them so I'm gonna
tell you here's what's gonna come I have
both Deb and Tom my family members will
groan when they hear I have four points
I'm going I'm going to give you and here
here they are this is what you're going
to hear in the next few minutes
first I'm going to tell you why
infrastructure gray as Stewart suggested
it was puzzling as it was and I thought
about this a number of months ago and
having a topic opposed actually is the
key to many of the most important
interesting even sexy questions in human
existence so that's going to be the
first argument I'm going to make make
for you and why infrastructure answers
one of the big questions that I
journalistically have been dealing with
through my career second I'm going to
try to explain why by default
infrastructure of all sorts important as
I am suggesting it is is under invested
in under attended to neglected almost
every society in every stage of history
has some kind of defective or or what
lagging lagging infrastructure third I'm
going to tell you what I have thought
about as the ways in which Americans
have avoided that default level of
infrastructure when we have done it what
are the special circumstances in which
that has occurred and then finally I'll
try to say what this means that we do
something about it
especially for you in the tech world so
that is the plan of action for the next
while to start with this first point of
why infrastructure matters is
interesting is an answer to some of
humanities of big big questions there
are some questions that people there
questions people know about through as
long as we've heard of people and will
will mole through the entirety of the
long now life-and-death peace and war
love and marriage or raising children
all that that sort of thing but there's
another one which is just below those in
prominence but at least to me has always
been very interesting which is the way
people organize themselves and the ways
in which that works and doesn't that
societies and countries and corporations
and organizations that seem to work
better and worse during my lifetime the
United States we've often thought about
this in competitive ways are this
Soviets better organized than we are are
the Japanese are the Chinese now
corporations have all their studies of
culture we have in when I used to study
economic
in graduate school there was development
economics of which societies were
handling it went one way or another and
even when when it's not in that strictly
competitive framework there's a sense of
well let us try to assess which things
work better and which things don't as a
as a side point one of the during the
years dev and I were living in China one
of the pleas I constantly made in the
articles in the Atlantic and radio
broadcast was for Americans to try to do
that thing which is hardest of all for
us to do which is to take another
country seriously without being afraid
of it now usually we take Russia Japan
whatever the Islamic world seriously
when we were afraid of betting the rest
of the time to hell with them with China
I think it's important to take it
seriously without being afraid of it
that's the separate speech you can get
on request later on the we know that
through history
there are all sorts of very worthy and
auguste people who have wrestled with
this question of societal and
organizational health or dysfunction
which things work better in which things
work worse and why they fail we have the
many volumes of Gibbon and the many
blames of Arnold Toynbee and Max Weber
and the Spengler and Barrington Moore
and other people we've all studied in
college at graduate school and I could
go down on the list what is interesting
to me is how the default level of
explanation largely in America but other
places too is when you see organizations
or countries or societies or
corporations doing better or worse the
default almost you know irresistible
explanation is to say it's a matter of
the people
for example the now leading candidate
for the Republican nomination talking
about the Mexican sending the rapists
and the criminals and some good people
etc this is this is something that is
distinctive at this moment in our
politics but has a very very long
tradition I mentioned a good point of
the Atlantic's history in 1860 when we
endorsed Abraham Lincoln a dark point
was in nineteen nineteen twenty five
when under the editorship of a zealot
editor
the Atlantic was a Maine Tribune for
saying keep out the Slavs keep out the
Greeks keep out the Italians keep out
the poles keep out the Jews these people
are not up to it and again it was these
people there were differences in racial
stock I don't even need to get into
America's original sin of slavery or the
history of scientific racism just saying
that it's worth recognizing as we go
down this path how powerful is the
instinct even here in a multi-ethnic
nation to think that people by their
essence are one way or another and to
sort of skip past organizational issues
and look at the people themselves here's
a side note for later reference
one of them saying that this is one
trait that is very strong in American
history that sort of default thought
that whoever is the newest group of
people is not up to the standards of the
previous one and that's been a constant
for as long as people have been coming
to this continent the other constant
which I mentioned hoping you'll remember
at about 20 minutes from now is that the
tradition of Americans feeling that
we're just about to go to hell that
since as long as there been people on
this continent there have been people
saying essentially what they say at the
latest Republican debates the things are
just falling apart the government is
terrible everything is bad we used to be
good and let's let's have it be good
again my friend Peter Hershberger's here
I recommended to him a book called the
American jeremiad by a scholar called
sack van Berkowitz you can guess that
his parents were students of a leftie
politics in the 1920s a call about how
starting from the 1630s Americans were
saying yeah it was great back there in
1620 but now justice it's just that
thinks you know it's about bad people
now so I recognize from American history
and world history this impulse to think
that people in their essence are wrong
women are not suitable so though blacks
are not suitable for citizenship etc etc
and through the decades I've tried I've
actually been obsessed with the question
of why how America is meeting its
challenges how it compares to other
civilizations and I've
tried to look at this explanation versus
other hypotheses in a number of avenues
I'll just tick off briefly I grew up in
Southern California in the 1960s so we
had the Golden Age of America under
under Pat Brown I didn't was in college
in the late sixties when things seemed
to be falling apart and actually were I
was in England for graduate school after
that studying economics where I had the
droll spectacle this is I I can't see if
you raise your hands but who's been to
study economics here I bet a lot of
people are raising their hands I've
become a permanent skeptic of economic
doctrine after being taught in this in
this conference room in Oxford or it was
like 41 degrees and you could see your
breath and the tutor had these horrible
little fingerless mittens that he was a
sort of an odd crane like or his name
was Nicholas Dimmesdale actually he was
telling me and he was giving me all the
principles of how economic theory taught
you that why nations would prosper I
thought you know this is what economic
theory brings me I'll stick I'll go to
some other other discipline but it you
know over the years Deb and I have lived
in Texas during its booms and busts
we've lived in Japan during the 1980s
during its its halcyon days I should
mention I worked for Jimmy Carter as a
speechwriter in the late 1970s when
everything really was was was dire and
and so I've been in these different
venues I've been trying to say how can
we think about whether America can
continue to write revived itself you
know after these warnings from 1630
onwards whether other society is we're
going to make it or not what England
ever gets central heating with the
Chinese make it where the Japanese make
it and what I have ended up thinking is
that as I've seen a lot of different
people in a lot of different societies
around the world and lived funnel a lot
of our family life outside the United
States I've become more and more
impressed by the universal energy energy
creativity ambition good humor of actual
people in most countries you go to you
travel one of these saving graces
between the US and China is that people
actually get along so well that's
between the two countries and so I think
that
become more more skeptical of the idea
that the raw stock of people is the main
differentiator and how organizations or
societies or economies improve I've
become more and more interested in the
systems through which these people with
the same human desire is the same
creativity the same ingenuity the same
hopes the same trepidations the same
belief in their children and all the
relatives which they're able to do more
or less with that that that energy and
my attention has been drawn to all of
the systems that either empower them to
do those things or frustrate them in
some way I'm talking about tangible
elements of these systems whether as a
country has has drinking water whether
it has paved roads whether in the old
days it had aqueducts whether now it has
broadband access whether it has air
ports whether it has all these other
physical manifestations of the tools
that allow people to do their work
realize their ambitions do more than
they could if they were stuck in a
little little village this is the time
to confess that Deb and I spent our
honeymoon in little villages in Ghana
and you may wonder why we're still
married these many decades later the
reason is we were there on honeymoon
when Richard Nixon took the u.s. off the
gold standard and the gun anne's would
not accept our dollars for the next
couple of months so we couldn't buy our
way out of the country so I was
impressed back then we so Deb couldn't
leave me because we couldn't I couldn't
change the dollars we we got through the
village life in Ghana and again
impressed me of people who are really
talented but were constrained by the
sort of physical infrastructure they had
there I mean also organizational things
and rural setting things whether there
are patents and public health systems
and rules for cooperation and
universities and public norms whether
there are things like expectations of
how you will drive your car who has
driven a car in China this is something
that I actually never drove one but I
was in a lot of them and it's an a
serious public health issue for China
the people don't know how to drive cars
the nation of first generation drivers
and it's it's it's one of many many of
these cultural things
accounting systems there's famous books
about how they ant the invention of
double-entry accounting was part of the
modern age
that's another one of these systems and
then there are cultural systems that
either encourage or impede people what I
used to call in an article I wrote about
the Philippines the radius of trust the
broader the radius of trust is the less
frictional cost there is of making sure
people aren't cheating you or you're
about to be robbed racial barriers
gender barriers tribal barriers all
these other things these things
collectively the hard properties through
which a society operates its roads in
this airports the telephone and it's
public health systems and all the rest
the organizational understandings by
which they can can conduct their
business and the cultural ideas of how
people can aspire what their their
limits are what can they can dream to I
call these all these things all wait for
it infrastructure because infrastructure
in the sense that these are the system's
visible and invisible evolved over time
and ones that try to cope catch up with
more gennadiy that allow people to use
their talents or not and that's why I
think the saga of the last 60 or 70
years in development around the world it
has been so dramatic because
infrastructure of various kinds that
have caught up has caught up so this
first point I'm telling you is that
through my life of travel as a reporter
and skeptic of economic theory and guy
fleeing the cold in England and then
going to - we actually were in Ghana
because we're so cold in England that's
why we went there for our honeymoon and
trying to explore all these different
societies going up and down I've been
impressed by the universality of of
people's talents and efforts and the
huge differential made by these systems
I think of collectively as
infrastructure this is obvious of course
but now I pointed out to you so this is
obvious now that I've pointed out let's
move move to point two why is it this is
going to be my assertion that almost
every society in different ways neglects
and under invests in these
various kinds of infrastructure that can
allow its people to reach their maximum
and to do that tend to the long-term
things and the short-term needs that
they have I will stipulate that you know
many as many of you know there's lots of
different familiar names for what I'm
talking about it were talking about
positive externalities we're talking
about the Protestant ethic and the
spirit of capitalism and network effects
and cognitive surpluses and Confucianism
and all the rest and there are
variations in those things but I'm
asking you for now to think of this as
one general system hardware and software
of how people organize themselves
collectively to make the most of their
of their their ambitions and it strikes
me as you look at these different kinds
of infrastructure you observe these
things about them one is that they are
both publicly and privately created the
government builds roads but the
government didn't build the search
engine embassy in industry the
government has the infrastructure the
infrastructure for the search end
industry but you have things that are
being built by the state building by
philanthropists being built by by
businesses etc so there's a variety of
ways in which these things come into
being
however they have despite those
differences in in origin there are three
things that are true in my view of
anything I'm going to call
infrastructure one of them is that the
individual benefits are not captured by
the person who creates them that's the
good part of it you're creating a public
benefit but it means the person doing
this the organization doing this is in
some way benefiting others and therefore
might beat it be tempted to under invest
in it a second tendency here is that the
benefits are not fully foreseeable I
don't have to tell anybody here about
how the the unintended consequences
mainly good sometimes bad a
technological innovation even the last
20 or 25 years but almost every stage of
technical breakthroughs they're an
infrastructure changes there have been
things that nobody nobody expected the
way that the car changed the settlement
pattern in the United States and many
eight many other effects
the third thing that is true of all
these in my view is that their payoff is
it exceeds the reasonable time horizon
of the person creating these things it
may be decades long and may be centuries
long but it's something that a purely
rational investor would not do so we
have things whose individual benefits
can't be captured by their creators
whose benefits aren't fully foreseeable
and that whose payoff isn't in in the
long term and it's also one other extra
benefit here is that often these
infrastructure investments not always
but often they disrupt somebody in the
here and now and a result of these
things I think is that in different
societies in different ways you have
less attention to the software and the
hardware that allows people to flourish
as I'm discussing then there might
ideally I might ideally be and so I
think that that's if we look around the
world I think in each country you can
imagine you can see the ways in which
this distortion under investment affects
it I'll just mention briefly China once
more we think of China as king of
infrastructure you go to China and
there's there were when I wrote my book
China airborne there were at that time
100 new airports being built in China in
any given time there's there's zero new
airports being built in the United
States you know they don't have that
many but it's it's been the main way
they tried to propel the economy during
the year and a half we lived in Shanghai
there were like four entire new subway
lines not stations but lines that opened
during that time and similarly in
Beijing but in China they have been
optimized for the hard infrastructure
but I argue that in almost all these
other soft ways all the cultural and
organizational things they are hitting
the limit of their their soft
infrastructure now one of the arguments
in in my book was was in fact that China
in the past 30 years has been a miracle
of going from peasantry to sort of
Dickensian industrialization and the
question is whether the next 30 years
will be going from Dickens to to having
Siemens and GE and Mitsubishi and all
these other advanced companies or or not
just being a bigger version of what it
is
and that's because of the organization's
the universities the the the the
increasing censorship I would argue that
in Japan the soft cultural barrier is is
the tribal racial consciousness there as
you know Japan's population is now
falling at a dramatic rate there are
projections that within 50 years
certainly within the long now horizon
its population could have fallen almost
by half and the reason is that
immigration which has been so important
to the United States is something that
is very very hard for Japan to absorb
that's their kind of infrastructure that
is difficult for for them we can go
through Europe and Latin America and and
the rest of the world I'll say that
let's talk about the United States now
of the ways in which we invest and don't
in infrastructure we had have had
various times where there have been
social barriers across the range
immigration has always been disruptive
through our history but what usually we
found ways to to accept it except during
the 1920's 1930's with this this cycle
we've had in the last say 30 or 40 years
has been a financial starvation of our
infrastructure where the East Coast has
physical infrastructure built in the mid
1800s the Midwest has physical
infrastructure from the late 1800s
California has it from sort of the early
part and mid part of the previous
century and it's all getting older and
the evolution or devolution of our
politics means it's been very hard for
us for us to address but it's worth
recognizing that through our history
even here even in the country that has
had the big continental ambitions that
has kept absorbing people from the rest
of the world that has prided itself on
continuing to open new opportunity most
dramatic infrastructure projects have
gotten through only by a miracle and I'm
talking about the I'll give you some
examples the Louisiana Purchase now you
know like the biggest no-brainer in
American history was very controversial
for Thomas Jefferson their impeachment
threats and various threats to him to
the Louisiana Purchase the Erie Canal
similar
the Gadsden purchased the Alaska
Purchase Seward's folly the Panama Canal
parts of the railroad system the
land-grant colleges the GI Bill even the
Atlantic the Atlantic during and after
World War Two wrote a lot of very good
stuff but it was home as where many
other publications to articles saying
the GI Bill was going to turn our
institutions into hobo jungles because
these people who are not really suitable
for higher education we're going to be
trooping in interstate freeways and all
the rest and you can if we are all I
hope to be here 50 years ago 50 years
from now I don't expect to be here 50
years from now but my son Tom come comes
here 50 years now you can judge whether
the current controversy over the
high-speed rail system is an example
that we look back on as we do the Golden
Gate which was controversial or whether
it's seen as one of the the small
category of infrastructure projects
which turned out poorly they caught us
all here I had a long one of my beats on
the Atlantic has been military policy I
wrote a book about thirty years ago
called national defense and I sort of
reap reached that early this year with a
long article called the tragedy of the
American military talking about our
predicament as a chickenhawk nation in
which were eternally at war but only a
tiny little sliver of the population is
actually exposed to war the the combined
American population is served in either
Iraq or Afghanistan or those theaters in
the past twelve years is less than one
percent of the entire population and so
you have this separation and it is its
head and I think that means that many
military projects the default view of
them is skepticism
you know the f-35 the f-22 one is right
to be skeptical of those the default
view of big civilian infrastructure
projects of the hardware type should be
embrace and optimism because the
historical record is that we over
imagine their short-term disruption the
NIMBY phenomena now the things aren't
going to work and we don't imagine the
things that will happen when the Golden
Gate Bridge is built when the GI Bill
revolutionizes higher education and and
all the rest
now I will and I'll just say so you
don't ask me why I didn't mention it of
course for the world as a whole the most
dramatically underinvested part of the
whole infrastructure issue is of course
our Clement emergency where for for
reasons that are specific to each
country but universal around the world
it's been not in anyone's interest to
deal with us which i think is it has to
be the next focus of the US and and
international politics I'm saying
wrapping up this second point that every
country has a hard time fulfilling its
entire range of infrastructure success
because this is always disruptive it's
disruptive in cost it's disruptive
ethnically as we're seeing in Japan and
even in the u.s. it's disruptive
organizationally as we see in China and
to people who hold incumbent power I
think as you survey that entire
landscape I would argue that still the
u.s. despite our financial under
investment in infrastructure and the
increasing polarization economically of
our population still is better
positioned infrastructure wise in the
broadest sense than any other country I
can give you the full version of that
rationale later on but I'll simply say
the ability to attract and outsized
share of the world's talent and have
them do their work here is something
that no no other country that is as open
as the scale we have no other country
that has our scale is as open this is a
unique advantage and there is still a
resilient power to this country but to
wrap up the second point every country
has reasons particular to it and also
ones that extend around the world for
not doing as much as it should or could
to create the systems that its people
need to do their work in the long run
point three there are ways in which the
u.s. in particular has found ways around
this challenge over its history there's
a reason we do have the Louisiana
Purchase and the national parks and
railroads and airports and all these
other things there's some things we
don't have but those are things we
achieved and I
like about it excuse me for a second it
strikes me that in the United States
there are three reasons why we're able
to overcome the stasis and do the things
we have done that's worth thinking about
these four for future reference and
future possibilities and those three
reasons are emergency stealth and a
story emergency I think is is is obvious
that when there are the World War two
you know the the New Deal didn't end the
depression as we know was made the
mobilisation of World War two that
suddenly got the demand kicked up there
are many times through American history
where you can see log jams of
disagreement and impacted interest being
broken by some emergency that then shift
us shifted us on to a different kind of
business from business as usual the
biggest mistake made by the United
States in the two years after the 9/11
attacks was to decide to invade Iraq the
greatest missed opportunity was not to
use that years worth of national unity
national political mobilization to do
something more than we did that is to
say anything now with it that a time of
when we could have done so much that
would be they would dress the nation's
long-term long term problems but
emergencies have a they are the almost
the only thing that can get political
paralysis out of its paralyzed situation
and it may well be that here in
California the drought situation could
be that this is we don't know how long a
drought will go on we know that if it
goes on much longer just the way of
doing business here can't be sustained
and so what this emergency it's not a
enemy attack but it's a genuine
emergency what that does to California's
ability to think about its housing
patterns its technology its resource use
and all the rest it's it's possible that
this will be a valuable emergency for
California and one of national and
international significance but that's
of the circumstances in which the US can
actually do something a sense of
emergency a second way in which the US
has been able to actually leap wave
forward is stealth subterfuge deceit by
which I mean the military budget this is
there's a wonderful book some of you may
have read called a country made by war
by Jeffrey parrot which clearly makes
the case that I've tried to make over
the years to that America distrusts and
hates and punishes anybody who uses the
term Industrial Policy but the way we've
actually done it is through the military
and it's not just a post-world War two
phenomenon it's back from that from the
Revolutionary War era where the small
machining industry was was fueled by
having contracts for the the muskets and
rifles for the the early Continental
Army and through that you find a lot of
the big infrastructure projects the
education projects other things that we
look back on as having built the nation
having had a military rationale because
that's something that allows you to say
well this isn't just big government this
is this is national defense how many
people here studied languages on the
National Defense Education Act the
languages I studied in high school
junior high and high school were Latin
and French the joke was Latin was when
we invaded Latin America I would be all
set
it's you know that this was how money
could be sluiced there and is still the
case that innovations in health from
from battlefield medicine the Veterans
Administration in the ways has tried to
do treatments all sorts of other things
the military has been the guys for
investments we are not allowed to make
other ways we know that this the Navy
Department the last six or seven years
has been one of the leading clean energy
departments of the entire government
along with with do-e because as I tried
to shift to to greener greener fuels
there is of course a codicil to this is
not purely the military it is also the
sort of the biotech and and medical
establishment the NIH the hospital
establishment that's been the other way
we've done it so it's better than it
would be better to have explicit actual
decisions about how we want to do these
things of
doing the groundwork for the Internet
not just through DARPA or through the
Defense Department but it's better than
nothing
because nothing seems to be our main
alternative for having these investments
in the national national interest and
the third way in which we've been able
to get off the dime and do something big
and break the normal bias against
infrastructure investment or changing
our rules is somebody who has had a
story that this was something that that
could make people look past their own
immediate financial interest their own
one-year or five-year time horizon their
own community and think about what would
be good for mation longer-run these have
had a variety of you know in retrospect
some of these look better than others
manifest destiny was one of the stories
that propelled the entire movement of
the white settlers across the continent
moving the Native Americans away but
also bringing them under United States
of America controlled that was a story
it's a story that was better and worse
but it was a story that got things going
during my childhood the space race now
john kennedy he was not afraid at all to
use the military threat but he was
saying we're going to land a man on the
moon by the end of this decade and then
the united states did there was a kind
of glory to that so in the 1920s there
was a continental excitement here in
california i would argue that the
governor's brown original governor brown
current governor brown original version
current governor brown current version
have have found ways to use these
stories to the Pat Brown of my childhood
was building universities and building
highways and opening parks and having
access to beaches and building the new
things for a new state and that was an
idea that might have made may had a
particular appeal for the Californians
of the post-world War two generation
which is when my parents came here from
their origin in Pennsylvania so many
other millions did too that was a story
that Pat Brown told during his original
incarnation the current Governor Brown
had a story more of that was like the
card
story I was telling in the White House
of limits were closing in trying to do
more with less etcetera and that may
have been appropriate at that time the
current Governor Brown has given the
current current Governor Brown current
edition has had a story of the long now
of this state of what it's meant through
history what it means to its people what
it can mean of the future what its
natural resources mean how to cope with
the drought about fiscal fiscal prudence
and I think that from his physical plans
to to the the railroad the high-speed
rail there's a sense of you may disagree
with him on a million details you may
not like taxes or whatever else but he
has a story he's telling and he's been
able to sort of move things so far in in
the state so to this this next point I'm
saying that said follow along so far
I've said that infrastructure of all
sorts is what allows aasaiya T's to
thrive most societies can't sustain as
much of it as they should and the US has
overcome this bias mainly through
emergency or through the military budget
or through stories that our leaders have
arisen to tell us from time to time so
this brings me to the last point I'm
going to make where I mean tell you I
think there is actually an American
story
to tell now that it's positive and could
make people think in your industry
around the country in different branches
of life that there is a better time
ahead for this country if we invest in
it if we don't just sort of hunker down
and protect what we what is ours and
make sure nobody nobody gets it gets a
share of it and here here's the prelude
I'm gonna tell you a little bit about
what Deb and I have been doing for the
last two years while we were living in
China the narrative we heard about the
United States was again as in 1630
things were going straight to hell that
that of course we had the financial
crash which had originated in the United
States as everybody in China mentioned
here Deb will cringe as I mention my
most embarrassing admission I will say
it here in public in China everybody was
sure
that I actually was george w bush if and
so so i got to hear this from people
directly now why are you starting all
these wars that crazy cheney you know
can't you keep him under control etc so
we got to hit you know that was not just
the people complaining to me as the 43rd
president but it was it was a larger
sense the united states once again was
on the ash heap of history on the
downward descent and that everything was
was sort of falling apart and that we
were polarizing as we certainly are or
economically and so wouldn't returned
from china we started a project about
two years ago of in our little propeller
plane a little four-seat single-engine
parachute equipped Cirrus sr22 going
from one smaller American city to
another and seeing how they were coping
with economic dislocation with natural
disaster with droughts with you name the
the factory closing you name the
hardship we want to see how these these
cities in Mississippi and in Vermont and
in South Carolina and South Dakota and
in Fresno and in San Bernardino were
coping with with all of their of their
of their travails and we've been for now
in hundreds of blog posts a number of of
of broadcast with marketplace radio
they've come out on the terrain with us
in a big story I'm going to do in the
Atlantic yeah they'll come out at the
beginning of next year we've tried to
say that if you didn't know that America
was going to hell
you actually would think it was doing
okay you would see lots of places where
people were finding ways to cope with
their challenges and circumstances and
that if the narrative you'd heard is
that was a good time for America than
the things you were seeing in
Mississippi and in in Michigan and these
other places actually would say yes this
is another time of creativity for the
United States let me give you just a
couple of details about this because
they sort of they support the story I
think it's our time to tell that
involves infrastructure in it this this
new age one of the things that is most
striking across this whole range of
cities we've been to in every part of
the country and we're still are doing
more traveling is that the politics that
is so poisonous at the national level
just
comes up no and and eat my favorite
example for this is de paired towns of
Burlington Vermont and Greenville South
Carolina Greenville South Carolina a way
right-wing town Jim DeMint was its
congressman trey Gowdy is now Bob Jones
University as their Romney carrier by 30
points Burlington is the home of Bernie
Sanders it's two parties are the
Democrats and the socialist Obama won by
30 points if you didn't know they were
opposites you would think they're the
same place they worked the same way you
have city managers working with
businesses working with the universities
working with the community colleges that
is one thing that is striking that we
think that America and it is the
national level at a not unprecedented ly
bad time because there was the Civil War
but at a pretty bad time of of national
politics at the local level it's the
kind of America you thought we were
supposed to have of people being
practical minded and too compromising
and thinking yes let's look to the long
term we've also been struck even in
places that show up in the paper only as
stories about misery in the heartland of
people who are presented in the national
press usually as the objects of this or
that huge national trend not feeling I
like objects at all filming as if their
community their neighborhood their
school their company was doing something
to make things a better and yes America
has every single problem we are all
familiar with and I've written about as
many of them as anyone here has has too
but there also is a sense of people
coping with that in it their talent time
and again we'd hear from people across
the country yeah this is really a bad
time for America but things look pretty
good here in Allentown where things look
pretty good here in Columbus Mississippi
or things look pretty good here in
Fresno I'll just I'll say more about
Fresno and Fresno and in a moment I know
that's sort of the shock value for a San
Francisco audience and the Fresno people
actually revel in that they revel in the
idea it's a really interesting thing is
the empowering force of being looked
down on that in one of our favorite
people we met it's a guy named Joe max
Higgins who is a son of an Arkansas
sheriff he's a
huge he's not very tall but he is huge a
burly guy who is the economic
development genius for the Golden
Triangle of Mississippi and he said when
they attracted a factory where Airbus
makes its helicopters in Mississippi he
said in Mississippi we're making [ __ ]
that flies in Mississippi and we all
still have a little taller because we
knew we were doing these things they're
the people who know they are looked down
on in Mississippi in West Virginia in
Fresno this is a sense that it gives
them a kind of motivation to to show
that they can do more we've seen a
fascinating opportunity equilibrium and
I'll mention this with great caution
here in San Francisco because you're
sort of Ground Zero of what I'm saying
there's an alternative to so the the
Ground Zero phenomenon that you all
represent and probably just people in
this room are the the the crown princes
and princesses of is the idea that if
you really are running things in the
country you're in Boston for academics
New York for finance DC for despair
Seattle in Seattle for Amazon the Bay
Area for everything you do here Los
Angeles for the industry and there are
other places Chicago galas etc but all
that stuff in the middle that's sort of
padding between the coasts it's it's
fascinating that even as that is
happening and you know and you see it in
all the trims here in San Francisco
a reverse talent migration is also
happening largely because of real-estate
prices people think in Fresno for
one-tenth the cost he plays in San
Francisco I can start an art studio I
can do a start-up whatever they're
saying that in Mississippi are saying it
in Duluth Minnesota or saying it all
over the place and in green Greenville
South Carolina so you've there is the
migration to the coast but there's more
of a reverse migration than you would
think usually people have to have some
reason to think yes I'm from this place
I have some so connection to me etc
there is a an interesting we all know or
hear or read in the paper that public
schools are yet another source of
despair about America on its way to the
ash heap yet
if you actually go to a lot of these
places this vital experimentation in
technical education and community
colleges and finding ways to connect
people who are not going to be doctors
or venture capitalists with higher
paying jobs than they would get at
Walmart and and so they could be they
could be welders they can be robotic
repairman I can give you Deb is written
a number of dispatches about this we've
seen a couple of other markers which I
offer to you as you travel around the
country if you do to to see whether
places are on the way up or not first is
whether people are living downtown again
now even in Mississippi even in South
Dakota that's been the marker of a place
that's coming back a second is whether
the Community College is revered and is
really involved with the businesses and
the third is of course whether there is
a brewpub no kidding that is a marker
for whether cities are on the way up and
we've been so we've been you know I
won't tell you any more about these
cities right now but what I'll say is we
have the sense from people we've become
allies with Peter Hershberger's here is
one of them the Marko foundation is one
the Kauffman Foundation people in the
maker movement of sensing that there is
something happening now that is
underappreciated that is under
registered in the national media which
are all about paralysis nothing happens
email scandal whatever that that that
that there is no room in the press for a
sense that lots of the answers are being
hatched sort of one by one city by city
not in a way that solves any of the
major problems we have yet but that it
matters and is different from what
people are thinking and a story that we
think we we Americans could tell is that
if we have the premise that everything
that's wrong right now is a different
bigger more garish version of what was
wrong during the first Gilded Gilded Age
we're almost everything we complain
about now happened then corrupt
judiciary corrupt politics disruption
through immigration disruption through
technology disruption through
globalization all these things they were
course were true
in the America of the 1880s through
1910s or so the response to that partly
involved national leaders who told a
different story including crucially
Teddy Roosevelt in a different way
Woodrow Wilson and the union movement
and and all the other movements that
that happened then but there was before
that across the country this myriad of
cities and states and regions saying we
have a way to deal with this new form of
Education with a high school with this
new form of finding ways to have people
work with this new form of suffrage of
course with women getting the vote that
in this new form of ethnic inclusion and
this is something that that I think the
argument I'm going to make in my
Atlantic article is the story for this
next stage of America is attending to
its infrastructure in the broadest sense
is a hopeful one that in fact people
across the country are using their wits
their ingenuity the opportunities the
local infrastructure gives them to find
solutions in their local area in
Mississippi in South Dakota in in
Vermont in Maine and other places and
they don't all know they're doing the
same thing and there's a virtue in
saying there actually is something
happening that can be assisted if it
could be more powerful if people know
it's natural thing and if people with at
the commanding heights of technology
like all of you also can see this and
find ways to use your products your
skills and all the rest to do it
including one other Gilded Age point one
of the the good size of the first Gilded
Age of course was that the new wealth of
that era endowed universities and
museums and art galleries and all these
events symphonies never everything else
and so one hopes that the wealth of this
era will be quickly put to it to use in
that way there are more things I could
tell you but I'm going to just bring
this to a close it's so long now but not
that long not Limina sleep long by
saying again what's become obvious to me
once I spent time thinking about it is
is this chain of logic I've tried to lay
out that over the millennia and around
the world people with the same amount of
raw same thing they want to do the same
same talents the same energy the same
passions what's made it possible for
them to do those things or not is the
systems they involve both they evolve
with physical systems cultural ones and
it's worth paying attention to that
infrastructure as the structural basis
for continued human ability to better
the condition of all of us and address
our problems like notably environmental
sustainability second debt there are
reasons why we all neglect these things
the United States strangely neglects
them less than other places have because
we have the soft infrastructure in
better shape in other places but we're
neglecting our hard infrastructure we
have found ways to trick ourselves into
doing the right thing here in United
States by emergencies or by the
military-industrial complex
or by a story which leads me to the last
point which is there is a story we could
tell the story is an America that is not
just in its final throes that is going
through the latest version of its
reinvention in which all the dire things
that are wrong now can be if not solved
at least addressed and buffered by
individual talent across the country but
also by the exceptional tools that the
tech industry is creating and mapping
and communications and in lowering
barriers to to opportunity and all all
the rest so as I have thought about the
long now of infrastructure today unlike
six months ago I actually care about
infrastructure I think it's important
and I think the way we can most
effectively advance the next stage of
America's broadest infrastructure
ambitions is by recognizing there's a
different story we can tell which
includes the bad parts but also as most
of our political discussion does not
includes the promising things that are
beginning to so with that I say thank
you for coming I look forward to
discussion
that's great I keep got a book there
well first an article good and together
tomorrow you're going to Albuquerque to
talk to an assembly of Mayors what are
you going to talk to those guys about
yes I'm going to so there's a big
gathering of mayor's in Albuquerque
tomorrow which is they're convening on
these issues I'm going to give them a
talk about what we've seen around them
around the country and many of them
we've we've met a side point is it's
common knowledge that being mayor's is a
good job it really can be a great job
that if you if you want to get something
done in politics being mayor and a
strong mayor system you can't do better
than that be President you think oh god
yeah and in cities they notice so take
climate you mentioned climate as a sort
of version of I think there's hard
infrastructure soft infrastructure which
is a great delineation and probably
natural infrastructure which may be a
stable climate is and the you know the
c40 the cities from around the world who
have been working on that seem to be
more effective than Nations is this sort
of indicative that cities take
infrastructure more yes that's a good
point and they can they can more easily
do things in the paralyzed politics of
today's Western nations you know China
has a different kind of paralysis I'll
say yeah but you know that the US has
very hard time as Obama is showing and
doing things naturally but California
can do things and cities can do things
too they can do something the question
from Sanjay wigle says the u.s. is under
investing hard and soft infrastructure
because of an ideology of privatization
of everything of everyone for himself at
privatization in terms that are not
government and privatization in terms of
you know oneself is there a way around
that or is that this situation I'll give
you my actual give you my actual view
everything I've said before is my actual
view but this is my preface it that way
because this is a little more
discouraging than what I was saying
before
I think we're in a we're in a cycle of
national politics we simply have to wait
out I think we're seeing the fruit of
Richard Nixon's Southern Strategy where
the Republicans thought they could make
themselves the party of the white South
and through Nixon and Reagan it was
their ticket to the presidency and now a
question is when will the Republicans
want to win the presidency again because
they're gonna have to change to win you
can't win the presidency just on white
Southern votes there was an old in
Britain but where we have sort of
sensible conservatives these days that's
the way conservatives get better as they
lose three times yes and I think it may
be more than that because yeah so we've
had you know the two Obama erases and
and anything could happen next time but
you'd have to bet on the Democrats just
on on on ethnic and demographic reason
but the reason I said they care about
winning the presidency is they still
hold the house in the Senate and most
individual Republican legislators are
safe in their districts so they have no
interest in in appealing to Latinos or
appealing to climate believers as I
guess I have to put it that way well no
wonder cities are doing stuff they
aren't getting it from anywhere else
they have - it sounds like it's oh sorry
I didn't hear that first no wonder
cities are doing so much stuff because
they can't count on the states or the
certainly the feds to do it needs to be
done and that certainly came up lots of
places and just to to make sure I'm not
a federal government nihilist so many
places see no no we're yeah so much the
public infrastructure was built in the
night by the WPA
right and an effective national
government is good but we're not going
to have one for awhile and that's just
the reality okay so we're going various
levels you're Damon raises the question
of global infrastructure will come from
governments from private sector how do
you incentivize global infrastructure
now we just got this big trade agreement
in the Pacific I guess that's a version
of soft infrastructure there is more
addressing of climate that's sort of a
version of a global taking on that issue
but is global infrastructure or
something that's part of fear so lots of
communication and transportation
infrastructure is being built like this
you know by people
in this room of whether it's some
satellite networks or whatever so that
is going along a pace it's where and
that's where the interest the various
nations more or less aligned and aligned
with those of the companies to accept
when it comes to China and information
freedom issues which is a whole separate
theme so I guess the question is where
the interests of the nations differ can
private groups deal with that and I
think they can't and that's why on the
bright side it's impressive to me that
China in the United States differ on ten
clear things any of us can name here but
probably our fifty five hundred other
things we're actually working together
pretty pretty closely including on on
climate issues question from Steve up
still you've come out for high-speed
rail you've probably heard of Elon Musk
Hyperloop
should we up the ante who in this room
knows enough about the Hyperloop to give
me a convincing answer to that is Elon
Musk here who I know so so the Hyperloop
seems to me like it sounds great but so
does my personal jetpack sound great and
so and so so if it if it's plausible
sure my my on my non expert impression
is it still is some ways away and the
the perfect system is the enemy of doing
something now ah okay so we're gonna do
this funky high-speed rail yeah make
sense
[Laughter]
so if there's somebody who's run should
be you know really really Street yeah
Paul Leo asks a couple of questions and
these are the longest most sort of
discursive essay like questions okay
well I gave a long yeah well that's the
one now people are you know going deep
here everybody goes to China that I know
Garret Gruner and very soon you they
come back to oh my god can these guys do
infrastructure and yeah yeah enter the
airport and you get this thing you go
into town and Shanghai blows your mind
and then these freeways are going
everywhere and they build the ghost
cities but then they populate them and
we can't build squat they're building
100 airports rebuilding zero and it's a
lot of pathetic us that comes out of
that storytelling
those are the people who've spent too
much time in downtown Beijing or
downtown Shanghai I see okay whenever I
read a newspaper column and I have
several specific people in mind saying
Oh Beijing is just like New York and I
say you know go another half mile and
it's just like you know just like
Guatemala or some area or just are they
not doing rural infrastructure yes so
let me give you my China my friendly
China bear thirty second thought tlit
which is I really I like being in China
Deb and I everyday we were living there
over the years we would say it's always
more interesting than it is horrible and
it was it was plenty horrible it was
always more thing we have lots of
genuine friends there and I think people
get along but China has so many problems
and the look of these airports and the
look of the high-speed rail are so
misleading about its overall connection
I think the maglev and Shanghai actually
who's taken the maglev in Shanghai your
mosa doesn't actually connect with the
subway system so we have our problems
but even the maglev there does tale
Kevin Kelly yes what it's so it's
well-documented the infrastructure
investment pays off a little more slowly
than of the first money so what is wrong
or what can be corrected about the
investment frame of thinking too
acknowledge that you're gonna be really
glad in 40 years time even though you're
really unhappy in the first five years
about this thing how do you do that
long-term investment what do you so from
the national perspective I think you
cannot do that in open debate we've
reached that point our national politics
you simply can't do anything this
election cycle or it's media cycle it's
the problem it's the media is the media
are part of it but it's I think
therefore the last at least in the Obama
period the Republican Party has
positioned itself as whatever he is for
they are against just to be against it
even if they used to be for it you know
then what the the Obamacare descended
from Romney care as a symbol of that so
I think that that it's there is a party
that has defined itself as blocking
national things so you can only do it by
subterfuge or some some kind by
executive order by military contracts so
politics net the reason why politicians
would gravitate towards infrastructure
projects is everybody likes a paving
contract in their home district rights
employment pays off right but but it
says something about ideology that
ideology now Trump's pork-barrel so that
that's whoa situation how do we get pork
bill back to my congressman brings home
the pork and my congressman stands up to
those damn liberals
space is a story that got going in the
60s and then people got excited about
and there was sort of a quiet period and
they're excited about again we're you
know we're seeing the movies written the
Martian and Andy waivers gonna come and
talk along now and space somehow is
attractive again it's a story and
there's a kind of a solar system level
of infrastructure that is being thought
of any second now people are going to
start talking about space colonies again
you're my mosque already is yeah and we
have some various people with large
amounts of money who are actually
privately had
into space Elon Musk being one of them
it's all that about is that an
infrastructure story or something else
yes I think that space has the potential
to be the next story it's inherently
interesting I haven't yet seen the movie
the Martian because I've been travelling
here since it came out but I really want
to and and things like that I gather it
has the sort of potential to be capture
people's imagination in a different way
from Star Wars or Star Trek which were
just video games in space essentially or
westerns in space and being about the
adventure of exploration so I place a
challenge to all of you
everybody here 99% of you are younger
than I am 99% of you are more in the
tech world than I am same proportion are
better financed than I am of finding
ways to dramatize the story of space
that can be as it was 50 years ago 50
plus years ago can it could be again I
think Julian says the American Society
of Civil Engineers is given the us
physical infrastructure ad- and believes
it will cause three point six trillion
dollars to get it up to snuff by 2020
what stories stealth or emergency will
make that happen
well tragically emergency you know okay
you'll have these collapsing bridges
this is one more I'll try to make this
the last time I sounded this theme it
would have been so easy and sensible to
have a giant bridge and highway program
as part of the stimulus package during
during the crash in 2009 but there just
was really doctrinaire opposition to
making it more than a certain certain
level and that was the time when you
could get the money practically for free
in terms of low interest rates and so
that it wasn't done then but emergencies
are actually rarely it likely to draw
people's attention Merck turn off from
the San Anselmo
he points out asked what nation do you
see as the best infrastructure for the
21st century and if US is number one
that would be swell but who's next I
think that the u.s. is clearly the best
position nation for the next next
generation the US has one
enemy as you're always here which is
itself that it is it's it's pathological
politics and it's if it's not able to
address all of our gilded ages excesses
but here's the case for the u.s. being
uniquely well-positioned it has we often
forget the scale we have it's the third
biggest nation in territory and the
third largest in population we have
let's say we have what five or six
percent of the world's population we I
would argue we may have two or three
times that many of the world's most
ambitious people because we're able to
absorb them and continue doing them our
universities despite our best efforts
are still very strong the the
technological situation in freh
structure that you all have created here
is if anything more powerful than it was
ten or fifteen years ago I believe that
China has enormous potential but there
are four times as many people they are
so so it's and I think it's hitting
various they're running out of young
people which presumably is an issue
they're running out of young people
they're running out of everything
my favorite aphorism when we got early
in our time in China some bureaucrat was
saying all of you Westerners think of
everything in China multiplied by 1.4
billion we think of it divided by 1.4
billion opportunity food land etc and so
I think they have a much harder road
ahead
globally there's continents and there's
oceans and certainly to my surprise
oceans it looks like shipping was going
to be something the task is everything
was going to go by every shipping is
huge and the oceans are being taken
seriously in a lot of ways of that they
weren't a while ago and is that your
perspective is that an infrastructure
story or is that what so the oceans are
another one of America's advantages they
buffer us except against the new enemy
of Mexico and that they and that they've
and also they're there we have a
unmatchable military military military
force I think that'd be what I hope
oceans could be as a story is both an
opportunity for exploration and a crisis
to address the ways in which oceans are
the frontier of sustainability issues
and climate issues so I that that would
be
also a story I'd be advancing if I were
running some tech company and saying yes
there's there's excitement here there's
resources there's adventure or there's
colonization and there's a real
challenge to be addressed how about
continents so Africa is it used to be
you go to one country and then to go to
another country had to go to Europe and
then come back yes you know they've got
a little more direct air and things like
that is Africa becoming a continent is
Latin America becoming a continent is
Eurasia
which was connected by Marco Polo and
the Silk Road and all that is it
becoming a continent stipulating and I'm
talking beyond my knowledge here well
I'll talk for a minute or two anyway I
think Latin America is for all of its
obvious fishers is more like a continent
than the others both because of its
shared they have a shared enemy of the
United States and they have they have
sort of similar languages you know
obvious differences similar heritage etc
China would like Central Asia to be a
continent and its continent as long as
Shenyang remains within their control
and as long as they can sort of build
all the infrastructure themselves across
the the New Silk Road Africa seems to me
becoming more different places Ghana
where we spent our honeymoon I think is
on the rise and there are resource
economies northern Africa of course is
entirely different so I think Africa is
the biggest of these regions is the one
most likely to be variegated and Latin
America is the one that has the most
common interest now they of you're
mentioned hard infrastructure which
everybody is what people think of as
instruction the image and soft
infrastructure and that's kind of new
and interesting and because of that
there's probably stealthy or other ways
to make great things happen there what
are some of the opportunities you see in
soft infrastructure I think there's
something that we take for granted as
part of our soft infrastructure that is
an a constant challenge and is worth
maintaining which is the
continued expansion of the opportunity
idea in America here is is is what I
mean again I've mentioned Peter
Hershberger a couple of times he showed
me a pamphlet was produced in 1921 I
think at a maker faire in New York City
talking about the varied nations that
contributed to the American miracle we
have the crafts of the Czechoslovakian
people are the Czech people the crafts
of the Finnish people the crafts of the
Greek people it was a way to sort of
buffer at the strangeness of absorbing
these we now think of court how could
you know Europeans be be a disruptive to
bring into the mix but the steady
expansion of making room for people is I
think the most important part of our
soft infrastructure I didn't mention
another of the traits of places we've
seen that are really working as cities
is they take efforts to make themselves
open they're receiving refugees they're
having the community colleges work in
the poorest neighborhoods and you see if
you if you thought America was actually
absorbing immigrants not having an
immigration war that would fit what you
see city by city by city yeah but not
enough the debates so you're looking at
a lot of small cities that dealing is in
soft and hard infrastructure issues and
other issues and it sounds yeah you're
telling a success story many places
they're all doing the same kind of right
things and there must be some that are
not sure and how does that work yes the
most troubled city we've been to is is
San Bernardino which is right near where
I grew up in Redlands and what's
interesting is they they compound the
economic blow is they've absorbed of the
compose closed Air Force Base and
railroad yard and interstate 15 moved to
Ontario they combine that with a really
uniquely dysfunctional City governance
system so the kind of practical
governance that we've seen at the state
level is uniquely absent in sammartino
and the cities that are in trouble it's
more likely to be a political problem in
an underlying economic problem because
economic problems you can adapt to and
whether illustration Allentown
Pennsylvania which you've all heard
about they have
they're really working hard on their
downtown and the problem is the school
system there which the city has no
control over so the parts they have
control over or actually on the way up
but the schools are the the sea anchor
on having more people moving to the town
both states they don't hear much about
states in your discourse and we heard a
lot about feds in a lot about cities
what about states what's their role
we've seen in some places the states
playing a big role for example in the
south there are a lot of these
governor's schools in South Carolina and
Mississippi and a version of them in
Georgia where relatively progressive
governor said we're going to have an art
school and a math school Mississippi
school for math and science if any of
you have been there it is a touching
inspiring and heartbreaking place of
what they are doing and I won't spend
time telling the story but so we've seen
state governments working the bad news
there is a column in yesterday's New
York Times by Tom Edsel saying the
paralysis of national politics is
spreading to the State House you're
having some of the same polarization
based on the 2010 census and so I think
there's probably going to be less
functionality out of the states and more
culture wars for the next couple of
years which increases the pressure on
mom localities one of the things I
noticed about cities we had Gavin Newsom
talking this series a while back and he
was going on about things going on in
Portland and things going on to Seattle
he's very aware of this kind of
comparative race to out improve the
situation between cities does that
happen between the states at all yes
have you heard of Rick Perry former
presidential candidate his his whole
shtick was moved to Texas and avoid
these terrible California taxes and so
yes and there's been a version of that
through 400 plus years of states in a
race to the bottom no it's true that's
there's no technical term
okay and it's so Mississippi a lot of
its industrialization is is factories
leaving the unionized north and that is
just just the reality of the industries
moving to Mississippi and so that is bad
for Michigan and it's good for
Mississippi and you can calculate the
net human welfare or law so by that
change yes there is very very vicious
I'll spend another 10 seconds Sioux
Falls in South Dakota is a great city
if you downtown is wonderful the way
they really got started 30 years ago
you'll notice when you pay your credit
card bill it goes to someplace in Sioux
Falls South Dakota that's because they
South Dakota raced with Delaware Nevada
and some other place to get rid of all
usury laws so the credit card companies
would be headquartered there and so they
used that as the beginning of their
economic comeback they've done more
respectable things since then but that
was how that was a race to the bottom on
usury laws is Bitcoin infrastructure as
stripe infrastructure as PayPal
infrastructure are these various
currency versions is that how society
also gets itself more powerful well to
the extent those barriers of previous
payment systems where you'd have to use
traveler's checks or we were stuck in
Ghana because they wouldn't change our
dollars that sort of thing that is hard
to imagine now so anything that that
reduces the barriers between people and
a good use of their activities their
their of their potential as part of the
infrastructure now of course criminals I
presume also pin speeds their way to
some extent but I think yes these are
part there's a part of the the
information revolution that makes more
of a people able to participate in the
entire world marketplace of ideas of
money of everything else there is a
little question about the infrastructure
of crime and how that works and whether
they can make the long-term investments
but they seem to have a most short-term
and long-term view they're in it for the
long term but so one of the questions in
here was what's infrastructure for
10,000 years what's you know step
outside the usual how long a bridge
lasts or railroad lasts or a college
education alas and what is
infrastructure for the multi century
scale we are obviously on in an area of
your unique expertise and my
my relative innocence I would say
interestingly of what any of us in this
room do what is likely to have the
greatest temporal permanence is
something we write on paper you know
paper has been a extremely durable
medium for things actually lasting the
digital media we know how often they
they churn maybe the cloud means that
data will be immortal not just in a way
that can embarrass you but you know over
the over the centuries to it maybe not
but it's been I know one was paper
invented the Egyptians so we still have
some of their Pyrus things that's only a
couple thousand years it's not ten
thousand years but I am struck we can
find there's some some emails I wrote
back when I got my first computer in the
late 1970s I just can't get anymore
because they were on Radio Shack tape
cassettes but things I wrote on on paper
50 or 60 years ago still exist and that
things that we have on the walls of the
Atlantic we have manuscripts by Thoreau
edited by Emerson and we have we have
Melville saying you know where's my damn
check no wait and we have the contract
with Harriet Beecher Stowe for the
Battle Hymn of the Republic for which we
paid three dollars to publish that in
the magazine so that was a wise
long-term investment what I would have
expected and direct write on paper or
you know it's that kind of cultural
continuity being able to refer to
something an area Beatrice no did is is
that part of what we're talking about
the soft infrastructure people long term
here is continuity continuity of good
things upward continuity we don't want
to have continuity of racism of tribal
suspicion everything but continuity of
recognizing the that a lot of the
problems some of the problems we face
are unique and new but a lot of them
people were facing 50 years ago and 200
years ago and maybe not a thousand years
ago but in that within the last 500
years people probably faced a lot of the
problem we faced of Aging although most
people were dead by 35 them and then but
but a lot of the human
we still read Shakespeare all these
centuries later because there's
something permanent we read Aeschylus we
see this play so I think continuity with
people who have found the best of
humanities reckoning with its limited
existence with its with its desire to be
immortal of reconciling there's two
contradictory things of recognizing
unlike other animals we're only here
temporarily we want to make some kind of
mark that that's the ongoing the ongoing
tension so in that timeframe I expect
that infrastructure looks like a good
investment yes yes in that timeframe and
any other I would say thank you thank
you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
you